so what is seeing how you remember he's
going and if you can come back to when
we spent on Monday I believe it was it's
a huge amount of times ability okay what
happens when you put more than what
angle inside a trigonometric function we
call the the compound angle identities
we significantly expanded your
repertoire identities these are
extension one I know the 10 a plus B I
didn't you
we got to our site on your site there we
move though the cars and they relocated
to sign a because so you just do the
practice and it's something will turn up
do you remember a book because we did
end up with a fraction you're just doing
the sum of angles we called it some
identities to ten what goes on the top
of the URL so in order to work out 10:08
mystique independently you need to be
able to have ten a and smooth be what's
the denominator okay excellent
third you remember as well that there's
those signs on the top to bottom they
alternate and just reforms move on to
the the next one on the board you can
use this to develop exact values for
angles that you didn't have exact values
so for example you may actually like to
do that really you may have done this as
one of your examples 75 degrees 75
degrees it's not one that we like
memorize 75 degrees it's not 30 or 45 or
60 but if you think about this as a
column you leave a beard as a compound
angle you can get it in terms of those
exact value pieces what would you write
and only one good so let's actually do
together just season join you memory
right get the UM get the gears turning
man if I write 75 as 30 plus 45 yes
tanto
10:30 over to 60,000 10:30 over to slice
of 60 yeah okay
the Schreyer is yes I can
60 will be happier to the value better
so do it too though it's a little part
of the record you can't do it it must
have a way that you can get into the WI
dentist shortly but this is certainly a
more direct part to it because like 30
45 or C so let's now use the identity
over there and expand salary what's
going to be on my team or 10:30 10:45
and then on your Dominator I just
subsidies right so 1 minus 45 can you
help me out 10 30 and 31 over a routine
huh icon tonight is whatever in three
hours at root 3 now you've got you've
got the triangular you can draw to help
you with map as much as possible bird
develop sort of quick accessible dollars
that you can rely on to help you get to
stuff like this can we don't know it's
not a sign because but sorry so 30 you
should be able to like involuntarily
think of a half when you see that right
and if you know that that half that
tells you a car 13 is right it's the
other one which is so when you do sign
Clarion confirm that which is what 10
that is right
what happens to be to state they cancel
which leaves you with 1 on retreat yes
you draw the triangle do whatever you
need to but I use as much as possible
with your brain rather than sort of a
pin into a calculator first because I
tell your brain gets stronger and better
at knowing these whatever 3 10.5 that to
be any one or that one okay that leaves
us with 1-1 on who 3 times 1 yeah
what kind of simplify this a little bit
because a bit of a mess at the moment
and amazing I dislike about this is it's
fractured bone fractures it's okay
probably the most efficient way to get
rid of all the fractions of fractions is
to choose something to multiply through
by on top on it gets your gold watch I
choose one on Route three we'll do it
right the trail do it I welcome to rush
or energy in a second but let's do it
once every time we get rid of fractions
of fractions first that turns that into
1 plus root 3 on the top yes
what am I getting on the bottom 3 root 3
minus by this one ok now I will
rationalize so I'll multiply by so
conveniently I'm just going to leave
that as squared what you're going to get
a derivative this squared minus this
squared that's 3 minus 1/2 is perfect
I'm happy to leave that there I mean you
could expand the top but it doesn't
really get much leaner does it if I can
you see more turns rather than lips you
can go ahead and you can check that into
your calculator to verify the size
exactly at 10:35 okay wonderful so we
have seen how moving this kind of
superchargers what you know about a
decade when we had 10 April the other
boy immediately the next thing was we
went to or what happens in person
difference members is there some do you
remember what changes will write it a
little note about the plastic ones humor
a little time yeah okay so this becomes
a plus listing of the writers just
sloppy design business right that now so
sometimes you'll see a textbook and it
once you put both of these formulas into
one so doesn't exciting we do it says 10
of a plus or minus P you see they're
just trying to pull these into one thing
equals now watch them just heal the
numerator the signs match postures get
pluses minuses good
yes so this fossil - and on the top take
a turn completely this plus or minus
will become plus or minus right so
you'll see this on the top the catch is
that when you look at the bottom these
sign T are they always mismatched
they're always opposite right so to use
will set them in there to use notation
in a bit appropriate way they're like
well I want the opposite way so instead
of writing flood - if you're home - plus
okay
they are my place yeah I kind of fibbed
about what they read you will see it
that's why I want you to recognize
what's going on base means the science
alternate but I think it's a little bit
size you like which is the plus - you're
kind of asking to confuse yourself so I
generally write them separately okay so
we saw there for the first line and for
the second one you can do stuff like
this we also use this result mode and we
need an importantly Boetticher look
there's we are we did some work in
college origin we went back to Twitter
geometry to use that second result so
work out does they don't remember what
did we do it in cones okay you've got a
pair of lights okay you can work out the
angle between those two lines we said
cared theta equals and there was this
big thing in absolute value some sort of
m1
we're using this one right this one's so
it's going to be the difference between
the two yes on one plus include because
we simply recognize if you just have a
single line don't worry about say that
will it you said a single line then any
good tan theta if you compare them or
you just put two ends and to dance
that's fine so we saw how we went from
here to here and from here to here this
is the reason why we are learning all
these trigonometric identities every
time you learn a new one it sort of
opens up it gives you access to things
equipped in before like any straight to
the angle to YouTube lines so this
morning we're going to take another
point of the tentative work and we're
going to see a door that it opens and
wonder if you can help me remember this
guy Egon is what's on the one this is
just a special version of someone right
what am i right suit and yes divided by
1 minus R 10 squared okay so this is the
double angle identity for 10 okay this
is where we're going to leave off so
I'll go to the studio I still have told
you the title you cut away how we get
there